welcome back one of my favorite things
about this show is highlighting great
people in the community we need to know
these people exist and check out what
they're doing and be inspired and
hopeful and feel secure that there is
goodness in this world and our next
guest is a mom of three who goes above
and beyond to make sure her community is
provided for from food drives to giving
out free haircuts
and school supplies angela torres finds
purpose in helping those in need welcome
angela
[Music]
thank you so much i'm so excited to be
here
i mean
what is something that drives you to
be so aware of others needs
i would say that i would i loved
volunteering from when i was a small
child just growing up in the bronx and
then when i became a mom i wanted to
help families and so i became a parent
advocate just speaking on behalf of
others and then also just helping in my
community in whatever way that i could
pas and ptas it's something from within
me that
helps me to
bring a little light in over the
pandemic you were able to feed what 5
000 families 5 000 families
it
gave you the idea to start a food pantry
tell me about that please
sure so um in april of of 2000 i lost my
mom to covid and she was a person who
was very
passionate about helping the community
and so at the same time i was very
involved in the pas and ptas in the area
and i was hearing from families who were
saying we don't have enough food
we really need help can you help us and
so i decided why not start a food pantry
and so um i got myself up and i said
we're gonna do this and so we started
this food pantry throughout the
community alliance and we are servicing
families and just trying to do so much
more because i really feel it's
important to make each person feel
valued
and so that's what's most important to
me
seriously
i
i need to go to the church of angela and
i can't imagine how proud your mother
must be and i'm so sorry
for that experience and that happening
and to make that choice as you so
eloquently
put it and
what do you do for yourself is there
anything you need to feed you
to be honest i get energized by helping
other people that's really what drives
me my husband jokes around that when i'm
sleeping i'm coming up with other ideas
as to how i can do something else and
i just i love doing this stuff
gosh you are a saint
and
i
you know
when you're sleeping and
taking notes on all the things you're
going to do the next day like what's
something you could use in your life to
you know
keep going i would say i would love
to maybe like redo a space in my home or
um yeah i i i find
recreating spaces you need a sanctuary
to go back to
recharge the batteries and this is
actually a surprise segment it's
designed by drew
[Applause]
i have to admit i got a little involved
in your life and
i may know what your bedroom looked like
before because this is it
um and it's lovely and beautiful
but if it's okay
behind those walls is a brand new
bedroom for you angela that i designed
oh my gosh
i wanted to do something for you
thank you so much
i'm speechless
good you deserve to be speechless you're
just giving giving giving and i also
think a place like this could be a great
sanctuary for you to come up with all
the wonderful things you do so i
actually changed your whole bedroom and
went with this creamy dreamy palette i
love it i wanted you to be able to face
plant
in that bed
and
you know or cozy up with like some tea
in a book whatever it is that you need
to keep doing what you do um a few
things that i thought of that were
important um was to put a mirror here
directly across from the window you have
yes what that does
is it tricks your eye into making you
think you have a second window so this
is a perfect economical brilliant design
trick
um i loved these bedside tables because
they have a nice surface area and they
actually have a drawer that seemed
really unique to me that is indented so
it actually gives
better depth
so i think that trickery also you have
to have a drawer bedside tables without
a drawer can go away
because we all know that bedroom drawer
is just like the kitchen drawer where
it's just got a bunch of crap in it
and and yet it's necessary
and i went with this really beautiful
um tufted headboard
because um i've when i was younger i was
always like i don't need a bed i'm just
gonna put pillows against a wall and
enough head banging and not the fun kind
um
i was like you know there's merit in
headboards
but i think a soft headboard is you know
really where it's at and the linens
please just come feel these linens
right
so here's your new bedroom angela thank
you
thank you i love it i love it thank you
thank you thank you so much i will
listen to your words and i will learn
and grow from them and i appreciate it
thank you so much thank you for being a
north star on behavior okay i want to
also give a special thank you to article
furniture for helping us create this
dream bedroom for angela they are the
best company by the way and i love them
because how many times do we go on
websites and they're like and in seven
to eight months you can have this
and you're like that's so not fun or
doable
article is like they actually have stuff
in stock i love them anyway thank you so
much uh to them and thank you
[Applause]
[Music]